well it was a simple decision that
really made a powerful impact emilia
martinez helped transport seven
strangers home on 9 11 after their
flight had been grounded today his
daughter las vegas is now's mercedes
martinez is connecting with one of those
passengers after 20 years christian
caseras has a story you'll only see here
on eight news now well brian denise
mercedes says her dad was a hero to
seven people that needed to get to their
families in denver on september 11. she
turned to social media to find them
today one of those strangers came
forward everyone says where were you on
9 11. well i can tell you exactly where
i was
and i will never forget it a difficult
memory for joyce blut who was grounded
in omaha that day while traveling from
colorado to chicago to visit her sick
mother in the midst of uncertainty she
knew she had to go back home but didn't
know how until something happened i
started to walk down the hall which was
just massive people
and there was this man and he held a
sign up
and it was like
oh my gosh
that man was emilio martinez who was
also trying to get home his sign said he
had a van and was looking for six people
heading to colorado
five men and two women trusted the man
that day who helped get them back home
this was the five year anniversary of my
father's passing he died from brain
cancer in 2016 and it's been really hard
but for some reason five years hit our
family really hard and we've been having
a lot of conversations about him and how
much we miss him and every year on 9 11
we always talk about what he did 20
years later emilio's daughter mercedes
martinez went on social media to find
those six strangers two worlds collided
two people who never knew each other one
coming from ohio to denver one going
from denver to chicago their lives
crossed paths for seven hours i wrote in
a van
with six people i don't know their names
i couldn't remember any of them but i
always remembered him
and you know mercedes talked about that
on the radio she put the play out on
social media and it's just amazing that
she didn't even know his name but that
20 years later she remembered of course
that day together it's amazing the power
of social media and obviously
bittersweet that they were able to um
you know connect uh she joyce was
telling us that she was heading over
to chicago to visit her sick mother and
unfortunately she was never able to see
her and to say her
her final goodbye but she also told us
that she can't seem to pull herself
together to watch any 911 coverage
because she says it's just so painful
um and she also uh just overall just
wants to remember 9 11 on what happened
to her on that day and just says that
her guardian angel was emilio wow so
hopefully hopefully
with the power of social media maybe
mercedes can connect with the other five
pounds the other passengers right yeah
the board will get around i was hoping
when i heard mercedes say that that
someone would reach out it's cool that
it happened yeah thanks incredible